would you would you rather have Olivia
Pierce as a mom or death's-head as
you're dead this is versus the GameSpot
show that pits your favorite games
console franchises and hot-button issues
against each other this week doom vers
Wolfenstein both series have a vast
history but we're going to turn our
attention to the most recent entries
doom 2016 and the machine games
Wolfenstein series fighting for Doom is
jean-luc set key he claims to have
beaten the game on the hardest
difficulty with the HUD turned off and
that he's also had sex with the
soundtrack only one of those things is
actually true but we'll let you figure
that one out yourself in the Wolfenstein
corner we have Kali plaguey
her desk might be covered with Pikachu
plushies but she's been slaying demons
and killing Nazis since she could hold a
controller each are going to argue the
corner for their game over the course of
three randomly picked topics with the
overall winner being decided by you
that's right the wonderful viewers last
episode Dave Newt Mike with 84% for
Fallout New Vegas
ouchy anyway to vote for who you think
argued their case better for this
episode we're gonna be throwing up a
clickable poll right here on YouTube
alright let's get into it
okay first one is gunplay so I think
what makes dooms gunplay unique to just
shooters in general is the way the
health system works and how you when you
lose health it encourages you to keep
attacking enemies because the main way
you get help back is from doing those
finishing moves on them so unlike most
games where you need to get in covering
you to hide it has this like forward
momentum to it where you're constantly
trying to like you need to murder more
and more demons to get your health up
and it just creates this like constant
forward movement that I think it's
pretty unique to do but the finishing
moves aren't with your guns they're with
your fists oh yeah we specifically
talking just guns I thought like it says
gunplay that's just okay I mean that's
fair but like you have to shoot them to
get them in that rate that you can shoot
in in Wolfenstein you can shoot Nazis so
we can move on from that and I would
like to point out that Wolfenstein has a
really wide variety of types of weapons
and a lot of customization on those
weapons and that customization was
improved in the new Colossus and I think
that provides more ways to play and you
can also do some stealthy stuff you
could put a silencer on your pistol that
changes you can't stealth ndu mister you
can't stop them do but do does have a
variety it's guns as well there's like
the two different attachments you can
pick and it's like similar it makes you
like pick and choose which one you want
to use so it's like you want to have
rockets to your assault rifle and you
want to touch this scope and we have
that too though well stern has that too
I'd say that's the draw man well I would
just say that I think the there are more
opportunities to use different kinds of
weapons in different ways in Wolfenstein
and doom you find yourself doing that
corridor shooter thing or that like kill
chamber where you're kind of like moving
around the sides of the walls right you
do that muffin Stein tube there's also
more opportunities to use weapons
creatively okay but I would also argue
that I think Doom allows you to so the
big issue I have with Wolfenstein is
that there are certain situations where
it like wants you to be more like
gung-ho and just like shoot them up like
it doesn't want you to stealth and I
find the fragility of BJ to be like a
little bit limiting in that because you
feel like I have to really sit here and
wait for the health and I have to keep
shooting them with doom it's more like I
can like you feel free to just like keep
shooting use any weapon you want like
it's it's more about just like
constantly switching between those
weapons and like just keeping the combat
going as much as possible where I feel
like Wolfenstein it has moments where it
forces you to stealth even if you maybe
don't want to and what I would say to
that is get bit all right next we have
level design and I think that one's just
a clear win for me because Wolfenstein
has a variety of level design where you
can go in stealthy or you could go in
guns blazing or you could kind of do a
combo of both or something till it goes
totally wrong you can adapt to that
whereas I think Doom can kind of be
limiting in that way especially if you
wanted to be a little more subtle
alright that's fair but I would argue
that a lot of Wolfenstein levels like
just aesthetically can be a little
generic especially new Colossus there's
a lot of bunkers there's a lot of just
like metal hallways with Nazis in them
which isn't bad but I think that they
may be lean on that a little too much
where I feel like Doom is constantly
trying to have new like interesting
environments you have like here's the
like smelting Factory where you have
like all this lob everywhere there's one
where you're climbing up the tower you
go to hell you're gonna help multiple
times but even everytime you go to hell
it's a very different looking version of
hell it will give you that I'll give you
that but I do think that part of level
design is not necessarily aesthetic and
it's also just in giving you the freedom
to approach that level of multiple ways
and I found that in Doom I there was one
way that seemed just like the way that
was the most efficient anything that I
try to do creatively was not very sick
maybe but I think the best levels in
doom are when they like open it up to
sort of like these massive like circular
arenas they have like the jump pads and
there's this flow of you constantly
moving around in circles like using like
different elevation to like get
advantage of certain enemy so I think it
like they're both very obviously they're
very different levels because they are
very different games the way you play
them my I think like dooms level design
like works perfectly with its mechanics
and like that you know needing to like
strafe around enemies and trying to like
kind of corral them in certain like
situations to like get them
appropriately yeah but after a while I
can get kind of tiring cuz like you I
mean like I really like doom right but I
I do think that sometimes going in that
same like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
strafe around this circular arena for a
while and yeah it's fast paced there's a
lot of action exciting but I I do think
that having that variety in Wolfenstein
really enhances the stakes in a lot of
ways and I think that benefits
Wolfenstein as a game more than it would
do but I I do find like as a player that
I liked being able to start a level and
approach it and if I failed like go in
and be like okay I know there's another
way I can do this I'm gonna figure that
out
okay that's very but I would say that
Wolfenstein is a little more uneven I
think Doom is pretty even cut in like
how it's like there was no level that I
felt like was bad there were some levels
in the new Wolfenstein that I felt were
weak there's the example the courtyard
level for example or not the courtyard
yeah the courthouse level but you
thought the courthouse was bad so I
didn't it didn't bother me as much as
other people I was actually able to get
through it reasonably fast compared to
some other people but I still felt like
they are throwing so many enemies at you
and you're so low on hell it was
frustrating because I had to put save a
lot and that's what I mean though that's
exactly the point like that there was a
narrative purpose to that there was a
and I appreciated that narrative purpose
but there did hit a threshold where I
was like okay this is just kind of
frustrating
I was like I have it in Dhoom 2 though I
never had that happen to me I dunno I
got no point did I feel like it had
suddenly jumped the difficulty spike
where I was like oh this suddenly got
like way too hard I feel like
Wolfenstein kind of like went back and
forth and a lot of that was like that
query or the courthouse one I think that
would have made a great life finale but
for them to put it in the middle of the
game felt like they kind of threw the
whole pacing out of whack yes I will
give you that it's a big spike in
difficulty but I do think that overall
that serves the game a rat story ok so
what's great about doom story is how it
doesn't care about its story um so the
game's story is like very much like
here's this guy he's fracking he'll
which first off that's genius I love the
idea of somebody fracking hell for
anybody getting it is pretty good that's
pretty good yeah and then it's like okay
everything goes wrong there's like a
call it feels typical like okay this is
kind of what I've expected not a doom
game
oh so people can criticize that that's
fine what I love about it is how the
protagonist doesn't care at all the the
protagonist like fits what like the
player is feeling we're like you have
this silent character who just like
dismisses everytime like the villain
tries to talk to him and every time
anyone tries to like convince him like
no we have to do this and I'm gonna give
this big monologue and he's just like I
don't care I'm gonna smash this console
I'm gonna destroy all this stuff because
he just wants to kill demons like that's
all that matters and I think that is
such a perfect story for doom because
when you think of the concept of doom
it's like it's a little limiting and I
think they did the best possible story
they could have done with a doom day I
appreciate that I will give you that but
I do think that Wolfenstein the original
Wolfenstein games could also be seen as
pretty limiting they were able to evolve
the character of BJ blaskowitz and
actually give it a story and he also has
that kind of like I don't care just want
to kill Nazis similar thing to do
I don't care I want to kill demons I
don't care wanna kill Nazis that's
pretty equal but then you also have a
really timely story that takes on a lot
of topics that I think games can shy
away from in a lot of ways especially
because Nazis are like the perfect video
game enemy because you know they're evil
and it's really easy to hate them you
don't feel bad about killing them but I
do think that Wolfenstein takes that and
expounds upon it a little bit it makes
you think a little bit more and then
also just kind of like it's very
consistent in its message that it's like
yeah we're gonna take this down the
system is not okay and we're going to
like I think that is all really valuable
and something that one side has been
building on since then you order and
really deliver it on with new Colossus
so I don't know I definitely agree and
like I think we both clearly liked these
games and I like that these game stories
in the weird ways are kind of like
balances to each other but what I like
is specifically about dues is how it
fits in the narrative of a video game
really well I I do feel like Wolfenstein
as much as I love the narrative and I
think the cub scenes are brilliant
there's is a little bit of a disconnect
between watching the cutscenes and
playing the game at times I feel like
dooms
story fits with the gameplay really well
like it feels like this is the perfect
story for a video game like it works
within the medium in a way that only a
video game could Wolfenstein the
cutscenes are really really well-made
but it's like I could watch a movie
about this and still for the most part
get the same feelings you know I I get
that like I get that argument but I
don't necessarily get that with
Wolfenstein because I do think that like
I mean even with the the courthouse
sequence that we talked about earlier
like that that's something where the
gameplay fed into the narrative really
well and like yeah there can be a
dissonance between the cutscene and when
you're going like just switching just to
having your gun in your hand and
shooting whatever I do think that those
things play off each other really well
so I think they're just two different
storytelling styles because I mean and
then also just like I you don't fight
Hitler but like that sequence with
Hitler is so powerful give you that bit
your liking is really good it's so good
and I think that yeah it's a cutscene
and maybe it takes you out of the game
playing
somewhat in some respects but I do think
that that is something that like only
Wolfenstein could have done in that way
because it was so cheeky but also really
serious and alternated between those two
moods like almost too quickly but like
in this way that was jarring and
upsetting and also just weirdly like you
kind of wanted to laugh at it like I
haven't gotten that emotion from
something since like inglourious
basterds so yes so who do you think won
the overall debate let us know by voting
in the poll on the top right corner of
the video or if you're over on
gamespot.com leave your thoughts in the
comments below remember it'll be your
votes that decides who wins so make
yourselves heard now let's get to the
quick fire round a series of dumb fun
questions written by the rest of the
team would you write would you rather
have Olivia Pierce as a mom or
death's-head as your dad I get revered
die Nazi scientist is your dad or a
woman who opens up a portal to Hell as
my mom I think I'll go with hell mom
okay
[Music]
Mary [ __ ] kill BJ doom guy John Romero
okay oh [ __ ] yeah Mary BJ I kill doom
guy and then I abstain yeah yeah marry
BJ children guy and John around
absolutely 100%
all right if your protagonist became
president what would be their first
order of business I think I think it's
pretty obvious that BJ would kill all of
the neo-nazis and doom guy would he'd
probably get rid of like like that oil
pipeline they're trying to build I feel
like he's like anti corporation because
that's like isn't like a whole metaphor
and doom like basically there before for
like fracking their fracking hell
okay so Dakota access pipeline versus no
more Nazis I feel like those are both
good there's a rough defense that's your
chance all right what is your
protagonist preferred social media
platform VJ loves Twitter
Grindr he doesn't really talk much so I
feel like you're with me tweet or
anything and grant you just need to show
like pictures so he would just show like
those two cabs he's got like he's got
that one outfit that just has the ads
like cut oh yeah yeah yeah no that's
perfect that's this profile picture yeah
yeah yeah um if you were in a date with
your protagonist what would the date be
subsequently what food would you have
what food what what food would you hand
feed them the morning after Mike Weisman
all right this is Joey
I would I would make BJ a traditional
American breakfast because I know that's
what he wouldn't want but you can't
really hand feed the sunny-side up eggs
so I would just stick with the waffles
maybe
I don't know you think doom guy would
eat a cupcake in the morning people like
cakes I don't know remember to get your
voice heard in our poll or in the
comments section below and tell us who
you think argued their case better and
if you enjoyed this episode of vs. make
sure to hit that subscribe button as
we'll have new episodes every Wednesday
thanks for watching
[Music]
you
you